ihr ziel war stärkste kraft zu werden
ich vermute mal sie sind trotzdem
zufrieden mit diesem ergebnis
also meinst hier war nicht stärkste
kraft zu werden ich hätte mich darüber
gefreut und ich bin auch froh mit diesen
22 23 das ist vollkommen in ordnung wir
sind volkspartei
die cdu ist es auch die anderen sind es
nicht mehr und für mich war wichtig dass
wir die arbeit auf den linken wieder zu
uns holen
das scheint uns gelungen zu sein und
deswegen finde ich das ergebnis gar
nicht schlecht am ende könnte es
trotzdem sein dass ein kleines minus
hier bei der afg steht wie erklären sie
sich das naja also wenn man fünf jahre
nicht viel hört von uns weil die medien
schlecht berichten die wohl die
landtagsarbeit dann nehme ich das zur
kenntnis trägt natürlich auch dazu bei
dass genau das bei rauskommt die medien
haben schlecht berichtet oder haben sie
auch schlechte arbeit gemacht
eine schlechte arbeit haben wir nicht
immer hat die medien schlecht berichtet
wenn ich die letzte berichterstattung
sehe der letzten drei wochen da wurde ja
eine menge hetze aus hier gibt da muss
man sich dann schon bei an die eigene
nase fassen und fragen ob das alles so
in ordnung war aber wir können damit
leben wir haben stammwähler polizei von
23 und 24
das ist vollkommen in ordnung für uns
als partei ist das gut dann haben sie
jetzt gelegenheit hier etwas anderes zu
sagen wenn wir schlecht berichtet haben
ich stelle da macht da drei fragezeichen
hinter aber was hat denn die afg in den
letzten fünf jahren hier im landtag
gemacht für die wähler also wir haben
ein haufen anträge eingebracht der
abgelehnt worden das war ein sehr
demokratisches verhalten auf der alb
hotel muss ich sagen hut ab dafür
ich muss aber auch sagen wir haben durch
die parlamentarische
untersuchungsausschüsse die wir hatten
und auch durch die verfassungsklagen die
wir ins land gebracht haben unseren
wählerauftrag erfüllt als
oppositionspartei wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass der wirtschaftsminister hat
lassen wurde wir haben dafür sorgt dass
die lotto toto gmbh dass die zwei
geschäftsführer gehen mussten
also wir haben ja eine menge filzmoser
aufgedeckt und wenn das unser nächster
auftrag ist dann machen wir das gerne
auch noch fünf jahre weiter was machen
sie konkret jetzt mit diesen 22 23
prozent wir müssen gucken was am ende
tatsächlich für eine zahl da steht das
noch relativ früh am abend jetzt was hat
der wähler davon dass er ihnen die
stimme gegeben hat der wähler hat davon
dass wir einen frosch in der cdu nach
links vielleicht auch mit diesem signal
verhindert haben weil ich glaube der
wähler hat der konservative wählt er
hatte in der letzten legislatur einer
teil konservative cdu bekommen mit zwei
linken kräften den grünen und der spd
als verlierer
und da muss ich sagen das haben die
wähler nicht gewählt und die wähler
wissen genau was sie wählen müssen
und vielleicht hält die demokratie in
sachsen hat ja doch noch mal einfach und
man kann ja konservative politik
zusammen machen
das bleibt dann bei den anderen also ich
bin gerne bereit dazu er kenne ich bin
der meinung hier herrscht demokratie
nach allem was ich weiß über dieses land
ist dass ein demokratisch regiert das
land
sie machen dann fragezeichen den finde
ich interessant haben sie denn für die
nächste legislatur vor und sie werden ja
davon gehen wir aus in der opposition
bleiben auch konstruktiv mit zu
bearbeiten oder bleiben sie eher in der
von fundamental opposition also wir
haben immer mitgearbeitet wir haben das
gemacht wir haben fundamental opposition
betrieben wir haben aber auch anträge
gestellt wir haben viele anträge mit den
linken zusammen selbst abgestimmt die
wahl positiv mit abgestimmt haben
umgekehrt ist das nicht so passiert und
das meine ich mit der demokratie wenn
ein wähler wenn er hier ist der
konservativ fehlt und der hype
konservative macht sich mit zwei linken
splitterparteien gemeinwohl macht mit
denen politik dann ist das nicht das was
die wähler gewählt haben und das sehe
ich eben das ist demokratisch ist das
kann ich mir das andere ja aber wie wie
gut das für das land ist dass ausnahmen
seien
herzlichen dank für dieses erste
interview ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen abend